The overall theme of the film, that I got from
anyway, was about a young girl, you know,
trying to find her purpose and trying to
figure out what she wants to do in life -
Yeah, which is kind of what we all go
through. Right! So it's really relatable
like especially when I was watching it I was like, God I can really relate to that.
Have you ever been in a point like that
yourself what have you always known what
you want to do? Totally not, and I think
that's why I kind of relate and I think
most people do. You know when I was
probably around, she's 20 when we meet her
in the film, and that was probably
during the time when I was working in
a Levi's store, I'd quit ballet school
which I thought was my gonna be my path
but I, my gut instinct told me that I
want to do something different I had
tried out for theatre school and I
didn't come in four times and I was going to go to university and I just remember 'cause I met I still kind of have
the same close friends that I met
when I was like 18, 17 and we said now
because now we're getting closer to 30
and I'm like "do you remember where we
just wanted to fast-forward?" 'cause I just
wanted to it was like so what is gonna
you know I just didn't know, what was
gonna happen and but that is also part
of I think a very important time when
you you also get to try different things
and I think like Lara in this film you
shouldn't feel pressured - a lot of people
around her telling her "you should step
into, you know the shoes of your dad,
you should follow his path" and she you
know, she says "no I'm not gonna". I mean
and she has a manor and all the riches
in the world but she wants to really, you
know, do her own thing and
find her own footing and find her own
path. You obviously had to do a lot of
physical training I can imagine for this
film. Yeah... You looked amazing.
Could you talk me through like, what
was your routine like in the gym and how
often did you train? Well yeah I mean it
was so many different skills of course
that I practiced for this role but I
also to be able to gain I gained about
10, 12 pounds of muscle and I had a
Magnet, my trainer who I worked with for
four months leading up to it
and then every day before I started to
film I was in the gym and something that
I learned was you know I've done much
more kind of yoga and Pilates and a lot
of cardio but
I started to integrate a lot more muscle
training a lot more and that is still do
none of the same level I did of course for the film but
that was something that I really enjoyed
I felt very much in my body and I loved
having another kind of strength.
Yeah and how often did you train, was it like every
day? It's five to six days a week. So pretty much every day. Yeah and then
Sundays was pizza day. Pizza day oh yeah, I bet you were waiting for Sundays to come around! No I think the first
thing I said when I woke up was "It's pizza day!" Do you have any like
quirky health or bonus tips that you did
during training? Or just in general? Yeah it's one of those things I know is
when I travel a lot like sleep. Oh my god
it changes the way you look, the way you
feel and the way, you know, how
you just feel generally in life at the
moment you know so that's something that
I know myself I'm like my mum used to
tell me when I was kid and when she said
I had to go to bed at 7:30,
I said "why?" she was like "well 'cause you do
get a bit grumpy when you don't have routines" and then I
realised when I'm old I was like, that is
actually true, mum. Speaking of like
the way you look and beauty and you know wellness and things like that, you obviously are doing lots of travel for the job,
do you have any like products and skincare things that you use?
Yeah because I mean of course now I have a
wonderful professional team to make me look,
you know put on my makeup for camera
and things but I very rarely use makeup
in my everyday life but I I love
skincare and if anything my skin goes
extremely dry so you will find me, I can
put like hand cream in my face
and it still kind of goes in so on flights and
things I always put on like masks or I
have I always have a night cream as my
day cream. That could work.